I hadn't planned on covering this
because there really isn't a huge amount
of information to work with but I've had
a number of people asking over the last
few weeks so I put together everything I
could find and in this short video we'll
discuss the story behind the divisions
first raid operation dark hours
[Music]
[Music]
when the dollar flew first found its way
into Washington DC important personnel
such as the president Secretary of
Defense and Joint Chiefs of Staff were
evacuated from the city there were
attacks on the Pentagon the National
Mall and several other landmarks
following this there were riots
eventually leading to the city's
security forces being overrun forcing
them to evacuate shortly after the heat
wave only added to the problems the
supply lines were cut off criminals
started banding together into larger
hostile factions fighting for supply and
control and any civilians who had
survived up until now have been forced
to join locked off armed communities for
protection while others desperate to
escape the chaos that was unfolding
flocked on mass to the Washington
National Airport looking for a way out
of the city however the gathering of
thousands of people in a single location
created one of the most dangerous hot
zones of the virus Sarah tried their
best to contain the area but eventually
had to concede the airport was coded in
DC 62 and insufficiently tested a cure
for the virus
this highly toxic chemical agent left a
trail of death and not just the airport
but all across Washington DC's most
populated areas Washington National
Airport was left abandoned and became
another dead zone to be added to the
growing list of uninhabitable areas in
DC
bring it forward a few months the black
tusks are attempting to extract the
broad-spectrum antivirals through the
base of tidal basin the division managed
for to stop to this as well as
eliminating BTS you operative Milla
withan redic as she attempts to launch a
missile strike on the White House with
their base a tidal basin now destroyed
the black tusks are in need of a new
base of operations abandoned with plenty
of space and just far enough away to go
unnoticed for a time Washington National
Airport was the perfect place for the
black tusk to establish a base and
continue to coordinate their operations
as well as use it as a supply depot to
feed the front lines within time the
division became aware of the new black
tusk stronghold across the river if they
were to stop the invasion of this new
enemy this is where they needed to start
or everything the division has managed
to stop so far would quickly be undone
by the steady stream of soldiers and
supplies coming from the airport however
what they weren't prepared for was the
new arsenal of enemies and technology
that the black tusk had brought in this
is unlike anything the shd had seen up
until now max Bailey otherwise known as
boomer is the first boss that the
division come across in the airport
boomer was a gifted athlete who had a
promising start in the United States
military during his time he said a 466
pound bench press record for his unit
that still stands today
he was eventually dishonorably
discharged for serious violent offenses
however the black tusk found him the
perfect candidate his raw strength and
fearless aggression made him perfect for
testing bulky experimental technology
equipped through the cutting-edge
defense unit boomers predicted from all
typical forms of damage and it includes
the ability to repair his armor boomers
downfall as his anger management issues
his temper has him losing control and
will cause them to medically chase down
targets this ultimately leads to its
destruction as the division agents
working as a team are able to easily
maneuver em into position and take down
his defenses
all of the Gordon or weasel is a black
task officer that doesn't come from a
military background he made a name for
himself in the private sector developing
military technology for the highest
bidder
Weiser was let go by his employer after
failing a routine psychological
assessment for sociopathic tendencies
but was quickly he attempted to buy one
of his best clients the black tusk
accompanied by two of the most highly
trained black tusk elites this is to
make up for his lack of combat
experience but also to keep an eye on
them as not even the black tusk trust
him completely
weasel makes use of experimental
chemical weapons in his fight to push
back the division this is of lethal but
it's incredibly debilitating of which he
is completely immune to through the use
of the very best in class chemical
protection gear black tusk engineers
have continued to work on their already
proven autonomous war hound technology
two of the latest models are codenamed
Lucy and Buddy they represent a huge
step up and lethality intelligence and
durability they're designed to work
closely together and are considered
inseparable equipped with mini guns
electric shock cannons and proximity
mines
they're able to put out a devastating
amount of damage but with an EMP
generator seeker mines and the ability
to repair themselves even hiding in
cover isn't an option and this isn't the
worst part buddy and Lucy are both
capable of boosting system performance
to a massively increased level critical
overcharge bypasses security protocols
and makes both war hounds considerably
more deadly and should be avoided at all
costs
the drone deployment platform mark 52 or
razorback for short is the latest in
technology that the black tusks have in
their arsenal it has the latest in
ceramic armor Tec which essentially
makes it impenetrable to traditional
firepower offensively the Razorback is
capable of missile attacks using Fang
micro missiles and the deployment of an
overwhelming number of semi-autonomous
combat drones due to the nature and cost
of this weapon the black tusk will
protect Ray's back at all costs they are
willing to devote all available
firepower including missile strikes if
necessary only through absolute
coordination of the division agents able
to take this behemoth down but all these
veteran bosses are newly created
technology aren't the biggest threat to
be discovered within operation dark
hours a far more sinister weapon can be
found with the dollar flew close to
being eradicated the black tusk has
plans to introduce a new more lethal
virus out into the public one with an
even larger incubation period ensuring
that more of the populace is infected
before the symptoms are shown and by
using these cute little blue teddy bears
that ran on spreading the virus through
the children of society
[Music]
yeah I completely made that up I have no
idea why there's so many blue teddy
bears around maybe there's a sale
maybe it's the latest in McDonald's
Happy Meal toys to be collected yeah
regardless sale is stupid urge to shoot
every single one of these little
bastards yes I have the commendation but
still I keep on shooting but as far as
the law behind the rate goes that's it
I'll keep on hunting but I don't feel
like we'll find anything else at the
stage hopefully future rates will offer
more in the way of story but for now I
thank you for watching and I'll catch
you in the next one Cheers
[Music]